guys before the video starts i'm trying
to raise three hundred thousand meals
for one thousand families in pakistan
yemen somalia bangladesh born sisters in
charlotte help us feed them this ramadan
to open and break their fast
and i'm gonna tell you guys what
happened to him he passed away
and i'm gonna tell you how he passed
away at the hands of another muslim
and subhanallah brothers sisters this
shows you how selfless
bilal was he subhanallah is in pakistan
what is it
this rivalry allah says in the quran
those who are fighting each other over
land
money property wealth may allah destroy
your wealth
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and citizens dear
friends hope you guys are well inshallah
welcome to this video
this video is going to be a video where
i'm going to try to speak calmly i'm
going to try to
not lose my call on my anger and that's
the reason why i wanted to do this video
a couple of days ago but i thought it's
not a good idea
i wanted to wait a bit because i know
i would have say things that i would
have regret while fasting
um so i'm going to try my best and i'm
going to tell you guys why
four years ago um brother sisters about
four years ago me and musa adnan and
shepard was done a
social experiment about hijab was
talking about hijab
uh but not men's uh women's hijab was
talking about ministry job and was just
quizzing people and saying you know what
do you think about the hijab and modesty
where's it going now
and a lot of people were talking about
you know sister hijab and the twist
behind the
uh experiment was that he was talking
about a men's hijab
and people were shocked they were like
you know they were talking about you
know sisters at all times they were just
trying to raise awareness that modesty
is both for men and women
in that documentary i mean in that
experiment
you'll realize that one brother stands
out if you watched it
and that brother subhanallah when i
heard of this news the first thing that
person i don't remember people's faces
that easy but he
automatically i i knew who the brother
was talking about immediately
and he really stood out in that
experiment because he was the only one
that
actually when we talked about hijab he
mentioned both the men
and the women and i found that amazing
he was a beautifully character person
like you can see this
within himself the way he was carrying
himself you know if he made a comment
which he believed was offensive to any
group how he would do not feel shy about
it
and i found that in him you know even
when i went in his shop
to do the experiment he didn't want to
decline me he said let's do it outside
you know
um and i said no problem you know due to
whatever reason it may be he didn't
decline me
you know he had a beautiful smile he was
a young man
and i'm going to tell you guys what
happened to him he passed away
and i'm going to tell you how he passed
away at the hands of another muslim
more closely someone that he knew maybe
his friend or family friend and i'm
going to come to that
this is the video of him in the
experiment i want you guys to watch this
so we can really truly fathom and
understand what kind of
what kind of a beautiful soul this man
was
hijab and modesty is headed in today's
time i think hijab odyssey
is becoming more like the hijab is
becoming more tighter i think and more
it's become more moderate in terms of
like for example i wouldn't wear
skinnies two years ago
yeah but now you've seeing hijabis
showing off their bodies
did you say you you wouldn't i wouldn't
wear skins i would laugh at them i'll
say oh that's
too gay out loud whatever but i wouldn't
wait i'd like loose
but now i wear them really tight i've
got tight jeans in this so
again okay so you're interested
that's very interesting you know why
because you're the only one and the
first one
because what is the trick question is
when we see modesty in hijab
we get a little brother starting you
know sisters and i'm like you even
talked about sisters i'm talking about
brothers
yeah i have to respect you the fact that
i said modest in hijab that you refer to
both male and females
that's the main message oh you have to
show them man because they don't know
yeah yeah my wife yeah
beats me man
i believe not covering your ankles for
example oh okay
lower gaze maybe i don't know lowercase
yeah lowercase is how you conduct
yourself
uh we should cover from our navel to our
knee no tight jeans
yeah so brother sisters what you saw
there subhan allah
is the brother now
this is the story and i've got it
verified with as much as i can
with close friends etc
and subhanallah brothers and sisters
this shows you how selfless
bilal was yeah how selfless bilal was
robin sisters yeah
he subhanallah is in pakistan and
he is made he's notified that
a person that he knows has oppressed
another person
so it's jummah it's a blessed day friday
he comes out of jummah and japan there's
rumors that he even
asked people to make dua before i don't
know if the specific day or before
that for him to die on the day of juma
was a martyr something along those lines
so he comes out of jummah and he's
notified of this
and fasting pray this allah
yeah and he's notified that a person
has had a land dispute and in this land
dispute he is
whatever it may be we don't know who's
right we don't know that specific
instance
he has caused the man to take his
clothes off and he burned his land and
made them walk over it or something
along those lines
yeah this is what we've been told and he
obviously hears this and he's
disturbed by this so he thinks look i
know him
let me go and talk to him and resolve
this issue you know
so it's not his dispute it's somebody
else's dispute
but he wanted to resolve the issue
so now he heads them and people tell him
don't go
he's got a gun so he thinks no
let me go like i know him and bear in
mind
i'm very sure in pakistan i'm sure he
could have access to a gun
i'm sure he could have a gun to go there
if he's hostile but he doesn't
take anything with him he goes there
brothers and sisters
and the moment he walks through the door
the moment he walks through the door in
ramadan
in ramadan fasting we're fasting
the moment he walks through the door he
is shot six times
six times his shot immediately
now this animal i'm going to call him
animal
i'm so sorry i'm i'm going to call him
an animal yeah
this animal pistol whips him three times
yeah he pistol whips him three times
in the face the question
i want to ask because i hear this
sometimes coming from the asian
community sometimes i'm not saying it
all
this happened last two years where
another brother killed a brother in cold
blood
in his house over a land may allah
destroy your lands
look i'm asking very simply if you're
going to kill each other
may allah destroy those lands what is it
this rivalry allah says in the quran
you are busy in the worldly affairs
competition
until you visit the graves no
then you will surely know and allah
repeats that statement
me while i and i mean this about my
heart those who are
fighting each other over land money
property wealth
may allah destroy your wealth i'm saying
may allah destroy your wealth this
ramadan the one i'm fasting
those who are killing each other over
land this person is not even his land
it's not even bilal's land
i don't i know that from experiment i
don't even know him closely
he is a brother in islam he is a brother
in islam
whoever this happens to for another
subhanallah we had a couple of months
ago innocent brother
selling clothes in his house got stabbed
in the neck
by individuals they're not even muslim
they're saying
you are a believer six times you shoot
him
six kids he had six kids
who's gonna father those kids huh who's
gonna when they come
to these kids where's your dad oh he's
shot down by another muslim why
some dispute over land of somebody else
he went into mediate
and now you're on the run run brother
run
are you going to run from allah and i'm
going to
give a verse in the quran and i'm going
to elaborate more and allah talks about
this two sons of adam alaihissalam yeah
we're the children of adam as well but
his two
blood sons in surah maidah
allah subhanahu wa tala says in verse 27
and recite to them the story of adam and
his two sons in truth
when they both made an offering to allah
and it was accepted from
one one of them but was not accepted
from the other
said and the other said i will surely
kill you
out of jealousy once was accepted yeah
i don't know what could be going through
somebody's head
for someone to be coming to sort of
matter that's what i have to do with him
and you know him family friends you know
him and you shoot him six times
bang bang bang and then you go pistol
whip him your animal
this animal behavior to another believer
a believer's blood is more dear to allah
than the kaaba
then the kaaba the lord of the kaaba
that the muslim's blood is more dear
and you know each other and i'm going to
come to something more shocking about
what bilal's mom said
when i spoke to his brother i was
shocked i was shocked
anyways this kind of reading this i will
surely kill you
said the former indeed allah accepts
from the righteous
said the other brother yeah if you
should raise your hand towards to kill
me
i should not raise my hand towards to
kill you
when bilal was shot he said to the guy
who was next to him
he shot me but help me
yeah but i could have come with the gun
as far as we know that could have come
with the gun when i hear this story it
reminds me of the situation if you
should raise your hand to kill me
i shall not raise my hand towards the
kill you indeed i fear allah
lord of the whole world worlds indeed i
want you to obtain
my sin and your sin so you will be among
the companions of the fire
and that is the recompense of for the
wrongdoing
and his soul permitted him the murder of
his brother so he killed him and became
among the losers
i don't know one lie there was one
instance in the park where a deranged
person whose
kind of uh thing and i had a bit of a
articulation she was every time he saw
to me and saw him coming to my face i
pushed him
i lose my call at one instance and i i
would never i would
i would never want to raise my hand to a
believer anybody
but you know and i kicked him
like i kicked him in the his you know
around his backside yeah i kicked him
out of my anger yeah
and this person we don't even know if he
recently said he's not muslim or
wherever he may be okay we don't even
know he's not
he's not like when he's not well i'm not
saying he's like he's a disability up
here he's
like he's able person yeah that i felt
bad
i was thinking man firstly i should know
better
and secondly he's a believer and that is
the reason why
we mohammed hijab we do videos attacking
a certain group who always attack the
believers
yeah always the believers should be soft
towards one another
for you in ramadan in ramadan
while i question if you feel allah and i
will write a question
anybody that kills a belief are one lie
in ramadan
fasting is it believer man is it
shooting someone six times what did he
do yaki
what did he do did he come and take kill
a believer from
your family so as we say it's kassas
what is it
did you do something to your female
family members what is it
six bullets and you whistle with him
my mind stops while riding my mind stops
i don't understand some people i don't
understand
do you not fear allah he's gone now may
allah accept him as a shaheed
i saw the picture of his body yeah
beautiful
with a smoke on his face you have
carried now his sins and on your qiyamah
you're gonna answer allah subhanahu
allah subs
his and the next of kin yeah
because i know this video is going to be
sent to you i know you're in the running
from britain
this is a photo from islam q a murder
killing a person deliberately
deliberately if the victim is a believer
is one of the greatest of major sins
because allah says in the interpretation
and whoever kills a believer
intentionally his recompense
is hell to abide therein and the wrath
and the curse of allah
are upon him and great punishment is
prepared for him
and it was narrated that the prophet
peace be peace and blessings of allah be
upon him said
and my imam will continue to be sound in
his religion so long as he does not shed
blood which is forbidden to shed
yes this can be more muslim or muslim if
you kill the believer deliberately then
there are three verse
three rights which are connected to that
right of allah the rights of the victim
and the rights of the victims next of
kin
with regards to the rights of allah if
you repent sincerely your law then allah
will accept your repentance because he
says
sayo ibadi all servants of minds who
have transgressed against themselves
verily allah gives all sins and is the
most forgiving the most merciful
with regards to the rights of the victim
he is not alive so you cannot put things
right with him
and your makayama
it's going to be peak it's going to be
peak yeah
on the day of resurrection you are going
to have to
give up your rights towards him yeah
talk his life
innocent person's life we're gonna come
to if you hear what the mom says you're
gonna be shocked guys
and in regards to the next of kin
but we live in a sharia government no we
don't and i'm talking about pakistan
even though it's i'm the islamic iran
handler the most beautiful thing that
allah
i spoke to his brother bilal subhan
allah
and you know what bilal goes because he
knows him the mother of bilal
uh bilal's brother he's telling me that
his mom saying
that if you guys try to go get us
you know it has to be done you know in
the right way and i spoke to them not to
do anything crazy
yeah because it's not right they should
not do that his mom said don't touch him
i forgive him
i was like wow i was like wow wow wow
wow like
like like i'm not i i i i'm amazed by
the
iman level that somebody does that to
your son may allah bless you auntie what
can you say
may allah bless you while i may allah
bless you that
she said i forgive him and told his sons
don't do don't do anything and don't do
anything i'm
and i told him myself don't leave in the
hands of a panel without
i found it amazing brothers and sisters
there's a sadaqa
that's for brother bilal i want you guys
to go and give for that inshallah
at the same time subhanallah i'm trying
to feed 300
raise 300 not me myself i'm trying to
raise 300 000 meals for people
in need in yemen palestine uh bangladesh
and yemen you can give to any the
sadhaka
is gonna be specifically there's gonna
be link there and the link to feed the
others do it on behalf of sadaqa
on behalf inshallah of prophet muslim
dead or alive i'm so disturbed by this
woman says wallahi i'm so so disturbed
and someone like bilal you know
subhanallah left
a widow a young wife six kids
how senseless you can be how senseless
how
johnny you cannot there's no one could
come and tell me that these kind of
people feel allah
no one can convince me and say this my
fears allah
and while i'm doing this video i'm not
angry i just want to cry i'm not angry
because what allah destined for bilal he
got it
i saw that picture one i'm not upset for
bilal in that context
what allah he is with his lord now yeah
the situation that he died in and you
are going to carry those sins like adam
alayhi salaam
where he did to his brother yeah what
you did to bilal
you could have and i'm not talking about
killing him per se
the way you took his life that that you
took his life
people would think it's bad in the
context and i put this in context for
you guys here
in the hereafter what you did to one lie
you
he probably thanks you to where he is
now
and now you're going to be carrying that
burden sin on the day of judgment and
inshallah mean that he enters jannah
inshallah so
don't think you've done any harm to him
no you haven't allah you haven't
you've done nothing no harm but to
yourself
may allah guide you
brother sisters
and if you want to give for the food
packages for the sake of subhanallah
you can make sure you do it in the name
of bilal may allah have mercy on him
what a beautiful soul
i'm honored to meet a beautiful man like
him
i'm honored that i interviewed him i
don't know him personally but i
interviewed him for a couple of seconds
and while i watching that video again
subhanallah says what a beautiful man
that i came across and shared a few
minutes of experience
reunite us all in jannah you're one man
after subhanallah isa
may allah have mercy and my brother um
in islam
who passed away mail every night
reunites in general you're another
person i would love to meet inshaallah
brown sisters may allah protect us may
allah protect us from shedding blood